on se souvient des propos de dominique
voynet cet hiver après le naufrage de
l'erika
la ministre de l'environnement avait
alors minimisé l'importance de la marée
noire
à l'époque son attitude avait été
critiquée aujourd'hui dominique bonnet
semble avoir oublié
elle passe même actuellement ses
vacances sur l'île de groix dans le
morbihan un site pollué par la marée
noire
véronique aurait les pires nique sur
place ici l'environnement de la ministre
c'est la mer la mer tout autour de groix
le soleil l'invite à s'y jeter et quand
elle remonte on voit qu'elle aimait ça
à la fois là deux araignées des dormeurs
en l'appelant à huawei
la plupart de ceux qui les consultent
discussions fort partir des souvenirs de
le temps
plus vieux
et aussi de momo radieux souvenir que le
partage maintenant avec sa fille jana
l'été dernier c'était dans une maison de
location d'années dans sa propre maison
l'une de ses collègues a posé ses
bagages d'été sur la même île et
d'autres ne sont pas loin sur une plage
de bretagne aux côtés de leur forme
physique dit aux médias c'est un média
comme non les aime bien les enfants
je me suis rendu compte qu'à dominique
voynet et marie george buffet qui est
avec le même il ya des mini vidéos c'est
la paralysie dans notre île dans ses
vacances la ramène au calme mais aussi
un peu malgré elle à l'erika le
pétrolier qui avons mis une partie de sa
marée noire sur les côtes de l'île
c'était en décembre sa manière de
relativiser la catastrophe avait alors
provoqué une autre tempête elle n'y
revient qu'à contrecoeur et préfère
redire qu'elle partage et comprends le
traumatisme provoqué par la pollution du
site dans lequel nous nous trouvons avec
les durand touché il n'est encore un
canton
propre sort des plages de sable et qu'on
regarde les infarctus de visites des
rocheuses on se rend compte que que la
marée noire a laissé des traces et
qu'elles vont durer plusieurs années
nous devons faire l'impossible cas se
reproduisent pas sept mois plus tard les
plaies jeux sont redevenus propres et le
malentendu entre la ministre et les
croisillons commence aussi à s'effacer
même s'il aurait préféré plus de
contrition moi je le 24 décembre j'ai vu
des oiseaux venir mourir à groix et
j'étais un petit peu en colère pour 2012
aujourd'hui vous voulez - certainement
plus que l a pas fait son mea culpa mais
au moins elle à l ai vu son droit elle
après un constat et
je pense que la seconde voilà aux airs
matinal des équipes de nettoyage
s'activent toujours sur les rochers car
c'est là que s'accroche encore des
plaques de goudron et dans la journée
qu'elles plongent calaio marché auquel
se baladent personnes ne viennent
empoisonner les vacances de la ministre
j'ai comme ça que sa fille elles
deviennent elles aussi un peu
brouillonne